Let me tell you one of my
favorite Yuletide stories
hails all around Chin Chin,
got to admit that some solid holiday wordplay.
There are infinite stories to be told
across the multiverse
We got the color of the suit right
I'm Santa Claus, baby.
Welcome back everyone It's Charlie, Happy holidays!
Marvel released a brand new
What If Season 2 trailer that is very holiday
themed like it's done to the 12 days of Christmas.
But there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs here.
Like, for example,
the Loki multiverse tree from the end of Loki season two
that he winds up creating when he becomes
the God form of Loki is in the trailer just in.
Hammer even comes back for a bunch of Iron
Man armor wars Easter eggs for the comics.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
of course I'll be doing videos for all the episodes.
The real big difference this year, though, is
that they're actually releasing one episode
every single day, starting on the 22nd
or like the night of the 21st.
I don't know if they're going to release
the episodes at midnight or like 6 p.m.
the day before, like they did with the Loki series.
they got really wonky with the way
they actually release stuff.
So they're actually just doing this one episode per day
for what If season two, the Echo episodes
which are dropping in January are dropping
all at the same time, like be in style
because there's only five of them,
but it's like a rated R series TV AMA
because it's way more hardcore Daredevil born again
apparently also going to be just like that too.
for those of you that have been hoping for like R rated
R like really hardcore Daredevil series,
kind of like the Netflix Daredevil series,
it sounds like they're going to fulfill that promise.
but just starting at the beginning of the trailer.
Working a way through.
Shot by shot, talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments.
they start the trailer with the 12 days of Christmas
Christmas Carol theme like this is obviously
all dropping during the holidays around the Christmas
holiday With the watcher basically talking
to Captain Carter about his favorite Christmas story
as he sort of spins around
like they're standing in the middle of the multiverse
and he spins things around in the middle of space
so the Captain Carter can actually see the depiction
of Loki's
multiverse tree, so to speak, So in order to do that,
she'd have to be on a higher dimension.
I explain this a little bit.
When Loki was actually building his multiverse tree
or repairing the multiverse
in fashioning it into a version of the world, treat
like a more cosmic version of the world Tree.
you basically have to picture Loki
sitting in the middle there, holding it all together,
like the way the showrunners talk about it
from the Loki season two series is that Loki is kind of
like the custodian of the multiverse now,
but they're basing him more on the God of stories.
Loki, who can actually time travel
within his own timeline, like God of stories.
Loki in the comics.
so at least for now I'm just calling him God Loki
But he's based on
like a couple different versions of Loki from the comics
they've obviously added
the Christmas decorations to Loki's multiverse tree
because of the Christmas theme of the episodes.
if you really wanted to get super deep on the weeds
here, like if this is actually existing
like they're actually Christmas decorations around
Loki's multiverse tree, but like, what does this mean?
What does this change about the multiverse?
That there's Christmas decorations everywhere
You have to imagine that every single little light
blue there is like a completely alternate universe.
So like these Christmas decorations
would have to be massive, massive in scale.
If you really think about it, Then there's
a quick montage of a bunch of different episodes.
This is from the hell episode.
What if Hela found the ten rings
basically were Hela gets banished
to earth in sort of like a replay of the events
of the first Thor movie,
but for Hela earlier in the timeline
because Hela was locked up before Thor was born.
so I think the idea is that instead of banishing her
to that other dimension present
that Odin did for all those thousands of years,
he banishes her to earth as a penance
it eventually winds up finding that alternate dimension
town from the Shang Chi movie and they take her in
she winds up turning good this way ends up being Wenwu
who works with her
when he has the ten rings to stop Odin.
And this looks like
sister from that scene episode two people wondering
there was supposed to be murder in the series.
I think this is what it's from it sounds like Odin
learns about the ten rings of the power
and he wants to take over the earth
because it is part of the nine realms.
Theoretically, in part of the whole back story
with Hela is that she and Odin conquered the nine
different realms and just stopped at nine realms
because Odin recanted and is like, you know what?
No, I don't want to be conquering res.
So he literally like,
stopped them conquering the universe at nine realms.
And that's why it's only nine realms.
Cate Blanchett did come back to voice the character
and she is supposed to be in a couple episodes.
I believe she's also going to be in the sixth
two episode as like
a version of Queen Elizabeth, the first,
because it's a big meta Easter egg.
if you didn't watch those movies,
Cate Blanchett a long time ago played Queen Elizabeth,
the younger version of the character.
And then there was like a sequel movie
where she played the older version of the character.
so the circle of Cate Blanchett Easter eggs is complete
in the 1602 episode
because this would actually been happening.
1602 is like right at the very tail end of Queen
Elizabeth's reign
when King James, the first took over
I think because they had Cate Blanchett coming back.
They're just saying that it was Hela instead of Queen
Elizabeth or King James.
And because she is Asgardian,
she lives for a long, long time.
so it just makes sense why she's still ruling over
planet Earth during that time period.
this scene of Nebula in the Rain is meant to be from the
What if Nebula joined the Nova Corps?
And that's sort of like an alternate history
where Thanos winds up being deposed.
Earlier in the timeline by Ronan, the accuser
not really sure how he winds up doing that.
But because of that, Nebula
wants to get out from under Thanos, his shadow.
So she winds up being recruited to the Nova Corps.
And you can actually see later in the trailer
she's wearing Yondu skin.
That episode is meant to be more of like a dark noir
Blade Runner crime thriller kind of episode
this scene of Gomorrah is from that Iron Man episode
that was supposed to happen during season
one where Iron Man got stuck onto the car
instead of Thor during the events of Thor Ragnarok.
So he winds up fighting in the contest of champions.
But their version of the contest of champions
is sort of like a junker race,
kind of like wacky races, because Iron Man's whole thing
is that he loves to race cars.
they just wait to building a bunch of Mad
Max style junker cars like he builds
the junker version of the Iron Man Hulkbuster armor,
the junk buster basically.
you could also call it the trash buster, too.
I think that Marvel actually sold toys
for that in real life.
Or if they haven't, they will eventually this scene,
a Thor seems like it's from the 1980s
Avengers episode where they wind up fighting Peter Quill
and his father ego the Living Planet.
But it's a younger version of Peter Quill
who winds up joining him and using their power
to try and take over the planet
in the universe. Eventually.
just like hell.
A part of the idea with Thor
is that because he's asgardian, he's like 1500 years old
during the events of the modern Marvel movies,
maybe just like a couple of years old with that,
because a couple of years
have gone by since then, but he's over 1500 years old.
so they're doing the 1980s version of the Avengers.
Like what is the Avengers form?
But in the 1980s,
Thor would essentially be the exact same look.
He would look the exact same.
Not that much time would have gone by for him
in reality, during the 1980s, Thor,
which is busy going on adventures with Loki,
the Warriors three, his father
like just basically having fun out
amongst the nine realms this scene of Iron Man is from
what did happy Hogan save Christmas
which is basically like a die hard style story.
We're happy Hogan has to save the Avengers tower
because Justin Hammer comes back in there stealing Iron
Man's armor and basically taking over
all their stuff is sort of a version
of Iron Man armor wars from the comics.
so this is like Jon Favreau
doing all this happy Hogan saving Christmas stuff.
Darcy, We got a Code Red.
The Avengers towers been overtaken on Christmas.
What is this corner? No, wait. Under siege.
No, no, that's not it.
Hey, John McClane, focus.
in obviously Sam Rockwell coming back to voice
Justin Hammer I know a lot of people
hoping that he comes back for the live action
version of the Armor Wars movie that they're now doing
instead of a series they're doing Armor Wars.
Is the movie at some point during Phase six,
The Avengers tower here that looks like it's inside
a snow globe is basically the watcher
looking into this reality with what if happy Hogan
save Christmas as if he's looking into a snow globe
but he's like looking into another reality.
and this features
all the original Avengers living at the Avengers Tower.
So it's before the events of Avengers Infinity War
and before the events of Captain America Civil War,
where they all wind up breaking up,
so to speak, Paul Rudd comes back
as Ant-Man during the Marvel 1602 episodes.
even though the trailer says 12 hulks are smashing,
I don't know
if that means that they'll actually be Hulk
in every single episode.
Probably not.
The red light here makes this scene look,
this is also from the Marvel six, you know, two episode.
The red light is actually coming from Scarlet, which is
chaos Magic, who's a big character during that episode.
And she'll be kind of like an MCU version of Merlin
during that,
Merlin is actually a marvel Canonical comic book
character.
He comes mostly from the Captain Britain comics,
but he's featured in a bunch of other comics too.
like the whole concept of Camelot, for instance,
they got into during the Eternals movie.
So there is a live action of Merlin
that was alive during that period, meaning
that he was probably a sorcerer supreme of his day
in a live action MCU.
And if it wasn't clear, because they haven't given
any voiceover dialog in the trailers.
But Elizabeth Olsen came back to do the Voice of Scarlet
Witch in all the different episodes.
The Scarlet Witch is going to be in.
there's a real quick shot of Howard the Duck for people
wanting Howard the duck to come back.
He was in what if season one episodes.
He actually got married to Darcy in that episode
maybe this shot of Rocket Raccoon is also from that
Nova core episode.
this is just Corey from that special Corey episode,
but she's in a couple episodes,
like you see a version of Avengers
Infinity War with Thanos coming after them,
the Infinity Gantlet
in like a more modern version of Captain America.
I'm not sure which episode
this Loki episode is going to be.
If he's also in that episode or it has something to do
with what Hela is doing during the series.
But he's wearing his classic Avengers armor.
Then we see that red skull is back
during those Marvel 1602 episodes fighting
what looks like a version of Bucky,
this episode with Darcy just seems like it's that
what if happy Hogan saved Christmas
and these men are just thugs working for Justin Hammer,
who's trying to take over the Avengers Tower
and all of Iron Man stuff.
this seems like Thor
from that same Christmas Justin Hammer episode,
but he's off doing something else,
pretending to be a version of Santa.
I think part of the idea doing that episode too,
is that Happy Hogan has to wind up saving The Avengers
now because all the original Avengers
are off doing other things at the moment.
this is the random shot of the watcher inside his base
which is like a pocket dimension in between universes
like that's why it looks like it's literally
in between two giant sheets with a bunch of facets
because it's between universes, zooming,
enhancing the bottom of the frame.
Here you can actually see a shard
into one of the other universes
with Thanos
screaming at him like Thanos could actually see him.
this episode of Korg and Groot playing
poker might be from that
Nova core episode just because things went down
differently during that universe.
this is meant to be just an hammer during that.
What if Happy Hogan saved Christmas episode
invading the Avengers Tower?
They kind of with a quick shot
of what looks like Oden catching Thor's hammer.
This might be when he's banishing Helo to Earth
because remember, the whole idea is the helo
wielded Thor's hammer before Thor wielded Thor's hammer.
just another shot from that happy Hogan episode
with the Iron Legion behind him.
So this is after the events of Avengers Age of Ultron,
when Iron Man created the Iron Legion.
we get to see Doctor Strange Supreme come back.
I'm not sure what he's doing in his regular episode
before they have their big Team-Up episode.
there's a real quick montage.
Then they end with a Sam Rockwell Justin Hammer
joke with him inside the Hulkbuster
joking about being a Santa Claus because Iron Man's red
and yellow suit is very similar to Santo's red suit.
so there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
going on in here.
If there's any footage that I didn't talk about
in the video that you spotted that you have questions
about, just write it below in the comments.
But my episodes will start on the 22nd
after they start posting them.
you know, just did a big X-Men 97 teaser trailer video
because Marvel also revealed
what's going on with all their 2024 animated series.
So you can click here to learn all about that
and all the other stuff that's coming in 2024.
There's a bunch of really cool stuff and click here
for my new Deadpool 3 Wolverine video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!